c'est toujours malade j'en ai marre ça
passe pas cette information était
essentiel je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez le jeu du times up
ça fait du bruit parce que je suis en
train de mettre la caméra en même temps
et on perd pas de temps dans le mental
blog ok mais moi j'adore ce jeu le
time's up je vais vous expliquer ce que
c'est rapidement mais je vais surtout
vous expliquer comment être un tueur à
ce jeu de société
salue donc le time's up c'est un jeu de
société où on met des noms de
personnalités de personnages et on doit
se les faire deviner par équipes en
trois phases
si vous n'avez pas ce jeu sachez qu'il
existe un site je vais trouver ce matin
qui s'appelle la bulle est fait le jeu
vous met le lien dans la description qui
vous apprend comment faire un petit
time's up maison en fait sans rien avec
un papier un crayon je crois que j'ai
toujours joué comme ça d'ailleurs dans
le jeu trois phases la première phase
vous devez par équipes faire deviner à
l'autre les noms que vous piochez et
vous avez le droit de dire tout ce que
vous voulez sauf le nom de la personne
c'est ce qui permet aussi de faire
deviner des noms qu'on ne connaît pas
toujours soi même ou que la personne en
face ne connaît pas puisqu'on a une
vraie liberté complète et il ya un
sablier deuxième phase ya toujours le
sablier là vous avez le droit de me
prononcer qu'un seul mot en disant un
seul mot la personne en face doit
trouver de qui vous parlez
waziers me phase c'est la phase du mime
et là vous avez compris il faut donc
miné les personnages que vous piochez
dit comme ça les phases ne paraissent
pas simple alors qu'en réalité comme on
tourne toujours sur les mêmes noms sur
le même paquet au fur et à mesure de la
partie vous savez un petit peu qui ya
dedans et c'est là dessus qu'on va se
baser pour optimiser nos chances de
gagner au down up dans la face une moi
j'utilise ma table de rappel pour ceux
qui viendraient l'arrivée sur la chaîne
et connaissent pas la table de rappel je
vous met un petit lien dans la
description et en utilisant une table de
rappel complètement classique 1 pouvait
même juste utiliser une table de 1 à 30
vous associer comme ça tous les
personnages qui passe vous faites les
images mentales et vous les avez de
stocker ce qui va être très pratique
pour la suite toujours dans la phase une
si c'est moi qui dois faire deviner à
mon partenaire je vais placer un mot
très fort fait je suis déjà en train
d'anticiper la phase de la phase 3 si
jamais on retombe nous mène sur ces
mêmes cartes par exemple si je dois
faire deviner tintin je vais dire tu
sais c'est un personnage de dessin animé
il a une coupe est comme ça une grosse
houppette jaune et il a un chien qui
s'appelle milou sait il va dire tintin
si je reproche la carte alors j'aurai
juste à placer le mot houppette en
deuxième phase et si c'est le mime
je vais faire ça et je sais déjà que ça
va lui faire un rappel avec ce qui s'est
passé précédemment
en fait vous êtes déjà en train de
modeler la manière de penser de vos
partenaires de la même manière
je prends un crayon ça montre à quel
point c'est sérieux si c'est pas vous
qui êtes en train de faire deviner une
carte c'est à dire si c'est votre
partenaire ou si c'est l'équipe adverse
fait l'effort au delà de retenir le nom
du personnage évidemment de repérer un
signal fort sur une gestuelle soit un
mot-clé très fort que vous allez pouvoir
réutiliser parfois ces mots clés très
forts n'ont même aucun rapport avec le
personnage ça peut avoir un rapport avec
la situation qui est en train de se
passer à ce moment là parce que
quelqu'un est en train de faire tomber
son verre par exemple par terre vous
avez juste à faire voir le verre et on
va se rappeler que c'est la personne et
que c'était tel personnage qu'on parlait
trouver ce qu'il ya de plus marquants
face2face 3 si c'est vous qui faites de
vie d'un mot donc vous placer le mot
fort ou le geste fort si c'est un mime
si c'est pas vous qu'on vous donne pas
les bonnes clés avec ces méthodes là
pour que vous trouviez passé en revue
votre table de rappel si possible juste
avant que ce soit votre tour parce que
ça va vous rafraîchir la mémoire sur
tous les personnages qui restent à
trouver et donc au fur et à mesure qu'on
retrouve les personnages dans ces phases
là ça va réduire un petit peu le champ
des possibles et vous avez beaucoup plus
rapides parfois il arrive qu'ils restent
plus que quelques cartes et que moi je
balance déjà tous les noms restants vous
c'est un peu l'anti jo j'avoue je vais
balancer les quatre personnages
d'affilée et pareil pour la carte
suivante la carte suivante puisque
j'aurai juste à chaque fois un vrai
conseil en face une est en phase iii
donc la phase on parle toujours la face
des rébus n'hésitez pas également à
faire des rébus si vous connaissez pas
le personnage ou si vous avec la
personne en face ne le connais pas faire
des rébus soit en mime ou des rébus avec
la voix ça fait gagner beaucoup de temps
et en faisant les rébus en place aussi
des mots forts ou peut-être des gestes
forts pour la suite si c'est en face
ville et voilà comme c'est samedi vous
allez devoir des amis où vous allez
peut-être à un moment donné proposer un
jeu et bien vous pourrez faire ce petit
time's up et commencez à vous entraîner
alors forcément si vous n'êtes pas hyper
au taquet sur la table de rappel c'est
pas grave le but c'était de gagner à
tous les coups non plus même si vous
pouvez essayer de faire ça mais on perd
le plaisir de jouer quand même mais vous
pouvez augmenter vos chances de gagner
et moi autant je suis pas mauvais
perdant photo si je peux gagner je me
porte le mieux merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo n'oubliez pas de laisser un
pouce en l'air parce que des fois vous
aimez bien mais vous oubliez de lemaître
passer un excellent week-end pensez à
vous abonner en cliquant ici juste avant
de partir ou juste là en bas à gauche et
rendez vous demain à 11 heures
ciao